this program is brought to you by Emory
University I think it's pretty clear
what all the outstanding issues are our
borders settlements Jerusalem
prerogatives of the Palestinian state I
think we don't yet have a conclusion on
what are you going to do with
Palestinian refugees and we don't have a
conclusion on the Palestinians willing
to accept Israel as a Jewish state we're
at the end of this debate it's a matter
of now leaders saying you know I i want
to i want to just bring it to an end and
finish with it but I think leaders who
say that have to face the prospect the
possibility that they'll get
assassinated we have a bed we have a
record of leaders in the Middle East who
have reached out to the other side and
lost their lives King Abdullah did in 51
Sadat did an 81 robine did in 95 I think
our fight was afraid to reach an
agreement in two thousand apart because
he was afraid what would happen I'm not
terribly positive that in the next four
months or in the next three or four
years you're going to reach an end to
this conflict there it it requires a lot
of nurturing if this administration goes
down a path of pushing hard on Israel in
2012 many of these senators and
congressmen will find that their
supporters might not be as helpful to
mr. Obama not necessarily in his
election but in the election of
congressmen and Senators when American
presidents become involved in outlining
what the conclusion should look like in
negotiations inevitably it fails
historically it failed and 69 with
Rogers it failed with Reagan and 82 it
failed with Carter in 77 78 American
presidents should not outline the final
statement of what it should look like we
should be involved in mediation no
question about it you need to to States
you need to stay for the Palestinians
you need a state for the Israelis as a
Jewish state they have to get out of
each other's lives the Palestinian state
has to be viable has to be contiguous
has to be able to sustain itself there's
no question that a two-state solution is
really the only solution to this
long-term coughlin but getting there is
very difficult the preceding program is
copyrighted by emory university